[Musique]
1973 c'est une révolution dans le monde
du meuble type qualité la france
découvre le meuble en kit lors d'un
salon qui lui est dédié à paris c'est
devenu synonyme d'un objet dans les
années 70 il commence à gagner du
terrain car pratique et pas cher pas tre
pas de perçage et la bibliothèque est
terminée en quelques années le meuble en
kit devient un réflexe pour les français
au point que le secteur du meuble à
l'ancienne souffre l'industrie française
est handicapé par une trop longue
tradition d'ébénisterie qui rend nos
produits trop chers et trop long à
fabriquer les bons vieux meubles à papy
supplanté par le kit notamment fabriqué
chez nos voisins les belges la phase
aiguë à vos appareils rester un pays où
on fabrique de très beaux meubles mais
sur un pan plus ou moins artisanal
laissons-nous l'opportunité de nous
implanter en territoire française le
meuble en kit a beau exister depuis les
années 50 la france ne s'y est mise
qu'au début des années 80 l'industrie
française
adam
dans cette voie annonce domaine de très
gros efforts à faire car nous y venons
effectivement et notre pays vient aussi
un peu après les autres c'est à dire
après des pays du nord est après
l'allemagne et le benelux qui eux ont
déjà fait une certaine évolution dans ce
sens effectivement la france engagé dans
la bataille du kit
sauf qu'un mastodonte débarque en 1981
le suédois ikea s'installe aux portes de
paris à l'époque c'est déjà le leader
international du marché du meuble à la
réussite c'est tout d'abord une idée de
base de marcheurs nous avons été les
premiers à vendre des meubles sur quatre
mais les premiers à faire des meubles en
kit les premiers à constituer une
collection de meubles aujourd'hui ikea
compte 355 magasins dans le monde dont
34 en france
l'entreprise progresse année après année
a bâti un empire au chiffre d'affaires
de 34,8 milliards d'euros en 2018
[Musique]